è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuto a questo
nuovo video io sono fan di j
oggi siamo su the doorway the doorway se
un indie horror che fa parte di quei
quattro horror che vi dico gli avevo
parlato nel blog che mi è stato
gentilmente fornito dalla casa di
produzione perché questa che andrò a
giocare ragazzi è una beta e una vetta
ciò vuol dire che il gioco originale non
è ancora uscito prima di cominciare la
capolavori che questo videogame
l'avevate consigliati in tanti e
fortunatamente la casa di produzione mi
ha contattato perché mi ha chiesto di
farlo e volevo dirvi che non si trova al
download di questo videogame ancora non
lo trovate in giro perché non è ancora
uscito praticamente questa versione che
che stiamo per vedere l'hanno giocata in
pochissimi perché la si può avere
semplicemente se se me la da la casa di
produzione perché non è pubblica e
quindi ragazzi mi hanno contattato mi
hanno chiesto di farlo è visto che me lo
avevate chiesto anche voi ha detto
perché no dato che piace e cioè le
immagini che ho visto sembrerebbe un
horror fantastico quindi ragazzi di lei
di tagliare la premessa e iniziamo
subito perché non vedo l'ora di
prendermi dei sani spaventi come al
solito per cambiare si perchè tanto
ormai sono abituato
morirò giovane brezec lei va bene raga
cominciamo
sarà fantastico non l'ho già incassati
su cos'è pisa
smart fifa
regione scudetto
per itunes store waits
raga ho fatto l'area da intellettuale ma
non ci ho capito una mazza ricotta ha
detto non ho idea di che cosa chapter
one the fuori stop states
ok ci siamo ragazzi capitolo 1 io io vi
giuro che quando uscirà questo videogame
andrò a giocarlo di sicuro perché è
fantastico ok siamo usciti dalla caverna
siamo fuori da ga siamo fuori
era lo vedono un horror in cui sei
all'aperto a parte slider vabbè comunque
raga vado avanti
madonna che buio mi chiama
un'accoglienza così ma neanche alla
regina d'inghilterra l'anno passato vj
accendete la luce paventiamo ragazzo e
siamo tutti uguali sti pot cos'è che è
successo
calmi quando diventa poi all'improvviso
non mi piace perfetto che sia allora che
andiamo avanti avrà una fine suo
percorso prima o poi di sicuro
vabbè tratto qua e purissimo non vedo
nulla accendete vi lurgi e non ci sono
le luci ragazzi che cazzo ti toglierà
con mio zio ragazze una tizia nel buio
che non era neanche tanto bella non c'è
una qua c'è un'altra via pratico sanchez
devo passare di qua si ci passa di qua
perché lì non si non ci tornerò mai più
cioè gli occhi di qua di qua c'è luce
cos'è questo
uno scemo trovato uno scettro bene posso
fare incantesimi come gandalf tu non
puoi mano forse serve per aspettatemi
fatemi vedere però c'è da tipo per
fargli prendere fuoco come funziona
adesso posso passare a prima non potevo
passare perché era buio
adesso evidentemente mi dovrebbe lasciar
passare se ho capito bene se non ho
capito non lo so raga io spero di non
incontrarla di nuovo nel dubbio coro nel
dubbio corro come una capra impazzita
vai cos'è cari ragazzi ho paura che mi
può dio
oddio io vi giuro che se ti sei rispunta
quella tizia glielo piccoli l'occhio
stop scettro non sarà a puntino nero
ok va bene prima che si spenga corrie
cos'è ok ci siamo ci siamo ci siano sia
ci siamo ci siamo c'è culo
ok è una sorta di check point per
riprendere il fuoco che perché dopo un
po si spegne perfetto da ci siamo sono
bravissimo sono bravissimi sono
bravissima vai avanti così non ti così
avanti così antico si paga di straziante
proseguire in questo modo se per caso
non si fosse capito eh io stanotte non
dormo mi sa
perfetto il 22 così buio buio cani
quando è buio stiamo calmi e tutti molto
calmi perfetto era solo un
cambio di zona perfetto ragazzina bene
io ho sempre meglio cos'è cos'è sta roba
è non vedo bene dove sto andando ma c'è
una roba spinata va bene io proseguo e
non ho neanche la torcia accesa bene
così raga e sto facendo esattamente il
contrario di quello che dovrei fare ma
andiamo avanti così il mio dio ezio mi
fa una pippa fantastico dove stiamo
andando di preciso raga non lo so perché
ci sta perché c'è una specie di edificio
in rottami così sembra vagamente una
mega baracca abbandonata non lo so ora
che non sono che che ci stanno a fare
stassi di legno
però io proseguo non solo non se ne sa
che noi dobbiamo arrivare sinceramente
c'è una
ma così quasi tornare indietro
buongiorno leggero che stavo scherzando
quando le ho detto che il tavolo scelto
in testa signorina lei è molto sexy io
quasi quasi si ragazzino qualche
chiletto la gara va bene non ti guardano
mai più il culo
bastava dirlo con gentilezza find
another way trova un'altra strada
perfetto ragazzi non sai dove telo fico
questo ragazzi sta ragazza è veramente
sexy cioè vi giuro nuovo testimonial di
intimissimi io vado via perché mi sto
seriamente prendendo male bene
raga che vi serva da lezione a tutti
quanti maschietti mai guardare il
culetto delle femminucce per strada
perché potrebbero girarsi male e non è
una bella cosa benissimo ragazzini mo
avanti c'è nulla ma si fa male questo
caso io mio crolla tutto ok è crollato
mezzo mondo ma sono ancora in piedi
bene così
andiamo avanti allora senti non ti
guardo il culo perché non ti fa piacere
ho capito si è perfetto
io vado di qua se non ti dispiace è una
giornata ma poi è tra l'altro vorrei
capire ma come ci sono finito a saltare
sulle travi cioè cosa faceva il giorno
prima questo c'è il voglio capire non lo
so la prossima tappa è quella di trovare
un navigatore ok ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla casa che sta nella copertina di the
doorway su questa qua e là la copertina
originale la casa mi ispira tantissimo
c'è chi ci andrà in vacanza molto
volentieri
tra l'altro uguale a quella lì the house
raga fantastico totò è sentite cioè
fuori j fuori nessuno che mi fa un te no
vabbè prendiamo la via sul retro
babilmente ci sarà una porta sul retro
benissimo entro la bellissima la casa
dentro guardate che atmosfera fantastica
adatta a tutti i bambini a c'è una porta
sul retro effettivamente me sbarrata
pure questa che cosa me l'hanno fatto a
fare sta a casa allora ci sarà qualcosa
infatti ciabattina che chiusa c'è la
cantina chiusa da un lucchetto benissimo
ma bello a sto punto dovremmo riuscire
aprire la cantina ragazzi entrare in una
casa così allegra partendo dalla cantina
mi sembra la cosa più bella che potessi
fare
ma se necessario piuttosto lo faccio che
cos'è sta roba
siamo cos'è una baracca lì c'è mica la
chiave del lucchetto probabilmente
ragazzo trovare la chiave o qualcosa per
distruggerla perché se no cioè non
entrano mai in cantina come faccio dove
la trovo ai qui perfetto l'ho trovata
per grandissimo eccolo allora l'ho vista
per caso pensavo di trovare un martello
in genere per le porte a scassare la
serratura e magari da blocchi in testa a
qualcuno non mi faceva schifo perfetto
da ragazzi siamo apriamo il trucchetto
devo selezionarla chiave mi sa che
perfetto ci siamo a pescara va benissimo
bello raga bellissimo non vedo l'ora di
entrare qui dentro
fantastico epico ragazzi poteva andare
meglio di così non credo proprio
la casa dei sogni ragazzino vorrebbe
abitare in questa reggia fantastica
permesso ho trovato la chiave nel
ripostiglio dietro sono qui per fare i
complimenti al proprietario della casa
per le pulizie perché veramente
fantastica che che scantinato doc
veramente certi nemica vini pregiati
sono un buongustaio raga non so
precisamente cosa ci sto a fare qui
dentro però ci si sa cos'è sta roba c'è
un'altra porta sul retro
tutto molto allegro vedo comunque è
l'unica via quindi direi di andare di
guar l'altro non ho preso più colpi
finalmente l'ultimo che ho prese quando
ero al buio perfetto forse dovevo stare
zitto perché poi è più buio di prima
comunque è la casa da fuori non mi
sembrava così grande qua sembra tipo una
cantina enorme sembrano prigioni
sotterranee lunghe chilometri che cazzo
era sto rumore ragazzi bruttissimo
enigmista sei tu raga sento dei rumori
bruttissimi mio dio ci girano solo 7
raga brutta cosa è bello fan fantastico
mi piace molto vi ringrazio per l'invito
sedermi ma guarda sto bene in piedi
io torno indietro perché leadership non
ci metto più piede benissimo c'è
un'altra strada qua prima era chiusa c'è
il fermo della porta che ho trovato un
pezzo di legno ragazzi l'utilità quindi
raga devo tornare indietro a vedere che
cosa c'era in questa stanza anche se non
ci tengo più di tanto però lo faccio per
me se c'è qualcuno wow
anche qua o no un nuovo invito ragazzi
probabilmente non vogliono anche sapere
che cosa ci facevano con questo e
torniamo indietro per niente mi servirà
più avanti quando trovo qualcosa dametto
accidente o qualcuno forse non lo so
cos'è il bagno questo dovrebbe essere
bagno mio dio sempre più puliti di
quelli la mia scuola comunque una
manovella trovato ho trovato una
manovella fantastico che cosa me ne
faccio è un cos'è trovato anche un
piccone questo luogo in testa a qualcuno
quindi direi che attorno a c'è ancora
strada qui c'è ancora benissimo sempre
più torture bene così un altro pezzo di
legno ora che sto diventando ricco di
legno
non lo so io al massimo al limite faccio
pinocchio tutta sta roba che ho trovato
non so che cosa farci se no
va bene non so che cosa c'è qui dietro
un importa un altro pezzo se vai così
pinocchio sono trovato il naso le giuro
che non volevo entrare mi hanno invitato
sono andato ragazzi se n'è andato non so
chi era non so chi fosse non me ne frega
niente via di qui non ho idea di chi
fosse quel tizio ma non mi è piaciuto
per niente va beh penso che sia il
proprietario della casa una parrucca
possono farlo caricarci una parrucca
benissimo
non penso sia proprio una parrucca ma
non importa che attrezzi nuti e
ragazzini servizi buongiorno mastro
geppetto
beh ragazzi ho trovato dopo 2 miliardi
di tentativi cioè la parrucca che andava
lì benissimo mi sembrava tanto geppetto
quel tizio comunque va bene penso sia il
proprietario della casa tanto fino a che
lo faccio io forse le torture a quel c'è
qualcosa da mettere penso che debba
mettere i pezzi di legno forse bloccare
si è uno solo più i pezzi di legno non
lo so forse tutti quanti tutti quanti
perfetto ragazzi io sto facendo delle
cose che non ho idea di che cosa mi
servono sincero
mio dio ma che cosa bruttissima
maledetto geppetto non pensavo mi ha
rovinato l'infanzia sto gioco mio dio
allora qualche cosa ci devo mettere non
voglio vedere ragazzi devo ricostruire
le torture in poche parole che qua però
dovevo metterla dietro e di vista
abbiamo scoperto dalle seguenti tale
l'enigmista e geppetto e lui praga nel
prossimo film di soge pezzo sarà
l'enigmista
comunque io ho paura di me no non ho qua
non voglio metterla ragazzi quando
voglio metterla di giuro cioè io io ho
paura di vedere che cazzo sta cosa che
brutto cioè sedersi sulle spine è di
sicuro più doloroso che vedere un'intera
puntata di dora l'esploratrice mio dio
ragazzi questa è veramente pesante
va bene che cosa cosa mi è rimasto là
che non lo voglio neanche sapere mi è
rimasto questo che cos'è ma non lo
voglio sapere è l'ultima stortura raga
credo che sia l'ultima spero non ne
voglio vedere più è questa che non
voglio vedere come nome non ci tengo
moltissimo a vederla provvediamo a sto
punto penso sia questo in teoria non lo
so bene così preparate i pop corn raga e
noi no aspettate non è finita c'è perché
non apparso niente
dov'è il mio morto voglio vedere tortore
raga che cazzo
va beh non è successo niente bene così
devo tirarla che cazzo devo fare
si possono mettere questo è questa la
doppia bellissima ragazzi bene così
ragazzi dovrei aver finito speriamo
perché non ne posso più di vedere
tortura e dovrebbe esso sia aperta la
porta spero di si non sia aperta porca
[ __ ] che cosa può fare ancora cioè
chiuso cosa vuole cesta leva qui che non
mi ci metto io piuttosto mappa pretty he
non funziona con lo chef non so che
cazzo co2 ma attuare con giro con in
testa di minchia
ma dai ma era lo scettro ma che cazzo ne
so io
ragazzi io vi giuro che sono stato 2 ora
girare intorno perché non trovava sta
merda
va bene ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo
aperto la porta
adesso voglio un [ __ ] the prepara
melo c'è perché bella ascensore moderno
ragazzi e sesto piano grazie è un pc e
redazione
e bello è sicura adesso stia senza dirci
personalmente non ci metterei mai piede
chapter working ce l'ho fatta va bene
allora ragazzi crederà la vetta di
doorways cielo quarto a finirlo e
promette veramente benissimo gioco
originale sarà fantastico
questo era il capitolo 1 ci saranno una
decina forse non lo so quando uscirà lo
farò di sicuro perché fantastico anche
ragazzi concludo qui se vi dove è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non
invidio trovata una descrizione sensi
nei prestiti iscrivete 20 ci rivediamo
il prossimo video bene ragazzi
[Musica]